In 1948, Harvard historian Arthur
Schlesinger surveyed academic experts
to conduct the first poll on
presidential greatness. The group named
six great presidents: Lincoln, Washington,
FDR,
Wilson, Jefferson, and Jackson. Only
Lincoln got all 55 votes for the top
rank. According to Schlesinger, the
great's had a lot in common. All were
identified with a crucial turning point;
all took timely actions to achieve
timeless results; all took the side of
reform. They were all party men; all were
strong, and has strong leaders they
aroused strong opposition; and none was a
great administrator. Since that time,
there had been many more surveys of
historians. C-SPAN conducted such surveys
in 2000, 2009, and 2017, and in all three
Lincoln was first overall, followed by
George Washington and FDR. In a December
2016 Fox News survey of registered
voters, 11% said Trump would be one of
the greatest presidents and 25% above
average. 31% expected him to be one of the worst.
Which of the six great
presidents do you think was the greatest?
Let us know in our poll. Also, let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and be
sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.